aventure sur la polémique qui est sore
cette semaine bien entendu et sur la f
histoire d'amour entre et Guillaume
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Janton adapté d'un programme américain
fr regroupe jeunes dans une villa du sud
de la
France
mais cette téléréalité diffusée depuis
le mois de novembre sur MTV et paramon
plus est aujourd'hui dans le viseur de
l'arcom et du gouvernement considéré
comme trash et provoquante frenchore où
la sexualité est presque omniprésente ne
cesse de faire débat ça choque sur le
plan morale cette semaine un baisé non
consenti entre deux candidats a même
suscité une vive polémique fou quoi et
le programme a déjà révélé des
personnalités forte comme Auriel qui ne
laisserait personne indifférent un de
courriel c'est chic chic chic don gu
est très jolie je l' envoyer un message
pour l'émission agression sexuelle
émission déjà culte Guillaume Janton les
stars de frenchy SH ce livre dans
TPMP bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir ça va les
chéris ça va vous avez discuté un peu en
DM avec Guillaume avant d'arriver ah il
y a plein de choses à dire il y a un
gros kpro je crois là ah oui oui on
s'est parlé mais ça a été une fois
c'était professionnel voilà il y avait
vraiment rien du tout et ça je l' teste
mais lui il me parle beaucoup de toi oui
mais ça alors en interne je sais pas
mais officiellement il y a juste il
parle beaucoup de oui oui vraiment
vraiment tu peux le confirmer Guillaume
non bah oui mais je l'aime bien elle est
très sympathiquep une très belle
personne voà c'est une très belle
personne aussi voilà mais c'est
professionnel c'est professionnel oui
c'est un crush quoi je professionnel j'
sens pas votre histoirei non mais si
mais si je la sens pas votre histoire je
te promets paka dis ce que tu as à dire
ou c'est toi tout jamais non mais c'est
bon bah moi je pens qu'il a plus non non
vas-y allez vas-y balance vas-y balance
balance il fait pas que dire c'est une
très belle personne tu disais elle était
très belle tout court bah oui elle est
très jolie c'est vrai elle est très
belle c'est gen complimenter sans for où
toi tu es ah ouais tu peux pas nous dire
si tu es en couple ou pas
ouais c'est compliqué je me pas trop le
tir mais
euh non mais il est très gentil c'est un
très beau garçon il y a pas de souci
mais il a non mais il s'accompagne elle
est enceinte en moi je suis très
respectueuse de tout ça donc on s
vraiment
allez euh on vaevoir des extraits voilà
de de l'émission et vous allez nous dire
voilà on va revenir sur les les
polémique aussi notamment les polémiques
on a voilà on en a on les a balayé cette
semaine après après je vais vous dire
dès qu'il y a un truc qui fait un carton
on parle de polémique hein c'est
toujours comme ça donc c'est plutôt bon
signe euh voilà tu voz c'est c'est c'est
c'est comme ça et puis voilà c'est
souvent des gens qui ne connaissent pas
euh le programme aussi des des et des
journalistes qui veulent qui veulent
aussi exister voilà il beaucoup de gens
qui veulent exister sur le succès des
autres vous allez avoir beaucoup de gens
qui vont vouloir exister à travers vous
nous c'est ce qui nous arrive depuis 14
ans et on est content de faire manger
énormément de gens en ce moment voilà
par exemple il y a th Ardisson qui veut
exister à travers nous un vieil
animateur qui veut revenir qui veut
revenir malheureusement donc il s'est
dit tiens je vais faire du buzz en
parlant deeux et oui ah là là allez P
Thierry j'espère qu'il nous regarde en
train de manger sa soupe ce soir à 20h47
fais attention de pas en mettre partout
allez euh qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
alors on va revenir sur les extraits
Enzo j'ai pas compris toi euh tu as
annoncé dès le début que tu aimais les
garçons ouais et euh frère il y a une
soirée boîte de nuit je t'ai vu pécho
tout le monde c'est que ça on va
regarder l'émission on va regarder on
regarder regarder non
mais physiquement donc ce soir ma
mission Vous prouvez que en étant
hétérosexuel je vous mets tous au piquet
les uns après les
autres oh non arrêtez mon alors là c'est
la Ribambelle j'en croise une je t'en
cape dégage une autre je t'en prends
comment tu t'appellees Léonie super ça
fait plaisir je t'ence dégage toi tu es
bien mignon tu es bien jolie je m'en
bats les couilles j'aime les mecs mais
vas-y hop je t'ence dégage les gars
votre TM si j'y rentre frérot je la fous
droit en deux il y a plus rien qui
existe vos piliers il se
dissoude Enzo j'ai pas compris tu es tu
peux expliquer bien sûr ou alors ce qui
s'est passé c'est que ce jour-là ça a
pas été montré c'est dommage tout au de
l'aventure il y avait Tristan du coup
Tho et Melvin qui me charit vachement à
l'idée que je faisais semblant d'être
gay que de toute façon même si j'étais
htro je pourrais jamais gérer leur meuf
j'aurais pas la côte et cetera et cetera
et du coup dans cet épisode là en
l'occurrence ils ont vachement forcé sur
le truc et j'aurais aimé que ce soit
montré je leur ai dit vous savez quoi ce
soir on va sortir en boîte de nuit faut
pas parler mandarin juste commenz pas
parler chinois et je suis allé au final
ben les meufs qui vouent gérer c'est moi
qui les encapé c'est tout fortcé
alors système du qu on t' vu on t'a vu
recal une meuf aussi on t'a vu recal
Julie il avait pas compris le principe
d'être gay et im les hommes mais elle a
quand même tenté
regardez moi je ne veux pas dormir et
vraiment mon chouchou c'est Enzo en fait
moi en plus je comprends pas s'il est g
ou pas donc franchement je veux vraiment
qu' me ce soir mon amour tu m'as fait tu
m'as
faitou tu veux pas moi mais je pas
rassurer tu vas faire des trucs sal je
CIS est vra
même si j'ai passé une trop bonne soirée
je suis quand même dégoûté parce que
j'ai pas mangé de aujourd'hui c'est une
journée végétarienne pour j'ai pas mangé
de aujourd'hui c'est
incroyable alors vous êtes rendu aussi
dans un dans un bargay pour faire
plaisir à Enzo et dans le but qu'il
pécho sauf que finalement c'est Riel
c'est vous qui avez beaucoup parler de
vous dans ce
bar le bar il est bien mais il y a
personne c'est pas grave on sait qu'on
est là pour s'amuser dans tous les cas
on est une famille on est ensemble mais
bon mon petit Enzo c'est pas ce soir qui
va se faire bâau encore pe gros flop
total monumental pour moi ça veut dire
je crois le mot flop il est doux comparé
à la situation qui se passe mais bon au
final on a kiffé entre potes on va dire
que c'est une soirée de l'amitié on a
tous passé une bonne soirée c'est
l'essentielle je pense qu'on oubliera
pas celle-là en revanche alors je l'aime
beaucoup elle est très sympathique Julie
elle travaillait dans boîte de nuit
avant par très fort l'impression qu'elle
passe toujours comme sielle éta en boî
nu ouais c'était super ça mais c'est un
truc de fou alors bon là ça s'est
transformé je vous montre les extraits
pour vous si vous connaissez pas frenchy
short c'est vraiment l'émission qui fait
le plus parler actuellement c'est un
truc de fou et Enzo on t'a vu aussi il y
a aussi des embrouilles dans dans cette
émission notamment avec Kiara l'une des
candidates ah ouais ouais ouais il un
bail le démon déjà frère vous êtes tous
là à dire on respecte les règles
cohésion mon cul les règles mon cul
arrêtez les je pr des moi aussi j'ai mal
dormi on a tous mal dormi j'étais par
terre sur ce truc
mouillé après mais est-ce que je Me'
prends quelqu'un ici est-ce que je m
prends quelqu'un ici c'est
bon tu cries arrte Enzo il est en boucle
et j'ai envie de lui rentrer un panini
dans la
bouche j'ai envie lui rentrer un panini
dans la bouche c'est magnifique mais
c'est Dr je l'avais même pas vu puisque
c'est dans l'épisode qui arrive ce
samedi ah ouais ouis on a on on est bien
on est
bien il y AEL un jour vous n'avez pas
vraiment eu de chance puisque Melvin a
été fricoté avec une autre fille de la
maison
ouais et pour vous ver vous avez voulu
coucher avec un autre candidat de la
maison qui voulait finalement prendre
son
temps la prochaine fois all voir
directement
guum sera beaucoup plus rapide
regarde la clam la gonor la de de merde
je suis trop vén m tu sais quoi tu vas
assumer prendre t temps de quoi ça fait
au moins 6 he qu'on se connaît mon temps
je l'ai pris depuis bien longtemps avec
toi Maxime bon l'équipe le
truc il est l'heure pour mon petit
Maxime de partir je suis dégoûté il m'a
pasé il s'en va à très bientôt la porte
de la SH family tu es toujours ouvert ah
non plus sur vendre le TR et oui mais
les caméras lui ont fait peur je crois
il a pas voulu passer le cap filmer
c'est bien dommage mais to il y avait
des garçons qui tomb plus dans
l'aventure ou pas
des garçons qui m'ont plu aventure ils
étaient tous très beau après du coup
j'aiis que des liens d'amié avec eux
parce que personne était réellement
ouvert à exploiter mon système bucal
donc allez peut-être Tristant j'aurais
dit Tristan et Nico qui est beau garçon
mais voilà ouais donc finalement
finalementouille ouis TR brouille alors
il y a une séquence qui a fait
énormément parler on va revenir dessus
c'est cette séquence qui a fait réagir
dit ch regardez c'est cette ils ont
appelé l'agression
sexuelle aut habitants point du doigt
Nico Melvin était clair qu'il ne voulait
pas embrasser de garçon donc on peut pas
lui imposer de galocher un garçon je
commence à m'imposer et j'ai même pas le
temp de finir que Nico est déjà dans la
bouche de Melvin et là oh mon
dieu W tu es fou ou quoi W tu es fou ou
quoi quoi qu'est-ce que tu as qu'est-ce
tuas
quoi ta gueule vous avez dit pas le
fa quoi
c'est un jeu j'avais demandé une seule
chose c'était pas d'embrasser des mecs
là franchement ça passe pas je l'ai là
et je suis venir contre tout le monde
vous êtes des fous ah je vous ai prévenu
vous faites les anciens
ouais ouais qu'est-ce que vous avez
pensé de cette
séquence ben ouais dans le fond moi en
plus qui suis gay du coup qui regarde la
scène avec du recul à l'instant où je
l'ai vécu j'avais dit catégoriquement au
fait que ça ne se produise pas alors
après je suis pas là pour jeter la
pierre à qui que ce soit mais à
l'instant Melvin nous pendant pendant
l'émission il avait stipulé quatre fois
CIN fois avant le jeu donc là on le voit
qu'une fois mais il avait vraiment fait
part du fait qu'il voulait pas du tout
embrasser de mec donc c'est vrai que ce
soit parti aussi loin je trouve ça à la
rigueur légitime maybe mais par rapport
au fait que ça a pas été réellement
consenti mais de là employer le terme
d'agression sexuelle alors que melvin et
Nico ont réglé le truc en interne et qui
s'est pas réellement senti agressé je
trouve que c'est un peu trop loin mais
je comprends par contre l'histoire du
consentement vraiment de ouf ouaisoua
non non moi je trouve ça maladroit alors
moi quand j'ai revu je me suis dit
pourquoi je me suis pas interposé pour
que ça arrive après c'est vrai que fren
SH comm on est très festif on rigole
tous ensemble c'est vrai que je pense
que ça aussi servi pour nous savoir
qu'il y a quand même des limites même si
tout le monde est très ouvert avec tout
le monde ça nous a tous un petit peu
calmé que maintenant en fait l'histoire
elle a été réglée en interne depuis bien
longtemps donc en fait tout ressort
maintenant mais Nico et Melvin ça a été
expliqué tout est ok par contre le
consentement c'est vrai que c'est
important même une main même un bisou
c'est super important de le dire mais
dans le cas de frenchy SH c'est vrai que
voilà c'était festif c'est peut-être
aller un peu loin au niveau agression
sexuelle maintenant je peux comprendre
que quand quelqu'un dit non c'est non
ouais c'est qu'il y avait des limites à
pas franchir en fait ça ouais oui non
mais oui je penseon peut pas parler
d'agression sexuelle moi ça m'aurait
choqué Ctait avec une femme par exemple
je trouve que deux mecs pour se
charier alors je va vous dire par
exemple si jamais je mettrai une main en
face à une femme si je mets une main au
fesse à Jean-Michel c'est pas une
agression sexuelle
voilài pour une rigolade mais exactement
il y a une différence quand même moi la
séquence personnellement elle me fait
rire et je trouve que la réaction est
marrante et le plus important c'est que
lui la victime entre guillemets ne l'est
pas perçu comme une agression sexuelle
oui c'est le plus important c'est que
mine soit ok avec ça paré plus
aujourd'hui on en a parler juste avant
enfin aujourd'hui il a plus mais après
c'est bien ce que vous dites là quand
même ce
soir homme ou femme quand on est jeune
et quand on regarde ça que ce soit clair
juste avant on a parlé d'un truc
d'agression sexuelle non consenti donc
c'est bien quandême là c'est dans le
cadre des French l'émission mais dans la
rue si tu veux pas un bisou c'est non
non c'est non un bisou mmeain c'est hy
important mais là dans le cadre de
l'émission c'était fun et le thème
agression a PR un
ouais mais c'est dommage qu'il y ait un
événement comme ça pour qu'on puisse
parler du constantement en fait c'est
dommage que soit le déclic pour parler
de ça mais c'est bien qu'on puiss parler
à travers l'émission C'est ça bon bah
très bien mais voilà bon sinon ça a été
l'aventure vous avez kiffé ou pas ah en
plus nous
deux la folie ou vraiment la folie la
folie c'est incroyable oua vraiment gros
gros kiff ou ah vraiment moi franchement
meilleur après j'ai que 21 ans 22 ans
mes meilleur expérience vraiment ah ou
quel âge toi 25 ça va plus oui mais bon
ça va ça va tuenvoies tuenvoies des DM
souvent toi oh
non non mais j'ai eu un son de cloche de
quelque chose dont je ne me souviens pas
vas-y va au bout de ta phrase qu'est-ce
que j'ai fait ça m'arrive vraiment mais
ça arrivein j'ai pas att FTI si
quelqu'un me plaît il y a pas de
problème je t'envoie un message c'est ok
pourquoi
t'inquiète reste
tranquille non non j'ai des bail sur au
j'ai des bail sur au ouais boctar aussi
euh non non c'est pas mais on a des BA
sur royel t'inquiète pas je ne dirai
rien non mais moi jeis all avec tout
hein tu sais bien non non mais
t'inquiète pas je ne dir rien reviens
lundi je je
dirai